Jack j'imagine ce qui se passe dans ta
tête en ce moment
[Musique]
chaque jour en cavale creuse un fossé
que tu pourras peut-être pas combler
je sais pas d'échapper à la CIA
alors pourquoi tu les as tous au cul
un petit groupe de partisans russe à
fomenté un plan pour préserver l'URSS
grâce à une arme nucléaire qui pourrait
créer le chaos c'est Tarma était
construite et elle est en route
il faut éliminer chaque
seconde compte
vous faites quoi j'improvise
[Musique]
Jacques si tu as un plan c'est
maintenant
je veux que tu as crayan soit arrêté
dans les plus brefs délais
combien il y a de chances que ce soit un
aller simple 80 90 % mon dernier vol
sera pas en classe